hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that everyone on the internet
is talking about it is of course
uh mato gbartel versus vladislav from
the european online club cup playoffs
around uh
three and uh it's uh well quite the game
story about the e4
already being on the board we're gonna
play it don't worry uh
and uh mateo bartel is a four times uh
polish national champion
and uh well you all know vlad we've
featured him many times on this channel
i think this is the first time either we
are featuring mateusz uh
so uh get ready for it as this is quite
an impressive game
so um with the white pieces opens with
e4 and here we have e5 so
nothing out of the ordinary we have
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
b5 the rule lopez is on the board
we have a6 morphy's defense and now
bishop to a4 even when we're not
covering the morphy saga we kind of
always have to mention morphy
we have knight to f6 and now knights the
c3 and here bishop the
c5 so the four knights sort of an
opening of the
rue lopez also known as the tarash
variation of the rue lopez
uh and here most common is just the
castle but uh mateos goes for bishop
captures on c6 and it's not a new idea
uh this
bishop for knight trading the royal opus
is uh very well known we have d captures
on c6 and the d3 now
adding another defender here preparing
to develop the the dark square bishop
so here you have to defend the e5 e5
pawn somehow you could do it maybe
bishop back to d6 maybe queen d6 maybe
queen e7
uh here artemiev goes for a queen to e7
and
now h3 not allowing any bishop to g for
action
uh and here there is a there is a quite
a famous game it was played
this year in the magnus carlsen
invitational magnus magnus uh himself
had this position against david anton
guiharo
uh where a knight the d7 was played
magnus was able to win this game
but here we have h6 and now it is
already as of move eight that we have a
completely new game
uh so let's see how it continues mateo
uh develops the light square bishop we
have bishop to e3
and even though uh vlad vladislav could
capture here and maybe
double white's e pawn it's not really
all that impressive you give white the
same you open
f file to attack you uh give him
additional support to execute the d4 and
this is uh these are none of the things
that black is interested in doing
so instead after this bishop to e3 with
bishop back to d6 and now
white castles uh we have c5 now uh
you no longer have to worry about white
pushing d4 here because it's just very
well protected
and now white needs to figure out how to
continue this game and here we have
knight
to d2 making room for this f4 pawn to be
pushed
uh at the 40 f pawn to be pushed to f4
and now g5 vlad
uh vladislav stops this as well now the
f4 square is also nicely protected as
well
as the d4 square and now knight to c4
putting pressure on the bishop here
with bishop to e6 continuing development
and now
knight captures and d6 with check uh
this is uh
this is an interesting capture but there
there i don't think there was a reason
to get rid of this bishop it wasn't
really doing anything it was pretty much
hemmed in
you know in between his own pawns and
this way you just uh fix black's pawn
structure but okay we have captures
captures and
now knight the e2 again white needs to
figure out how to create some sort of a
breakthrough in the position because if
you don't
uh then all you're doing is waiting for
black to make some sort of a
breakthrough and here knight to e2
most likely with the idea of c3 and d4
uh but artemia does not allow that he
pushes g4
and now already g captures on h3 could
be pretty pretty big
the h3 also is covered twice by the
bishop rook is coming to g8 then why
black also might have some ideas of
castling queen side bringing the other
rook into the attack as well
so a lot of ideas here and the white
does not want to open up the g
file so h4 and now knight to h5 bringing
the knight into the attack also
threatening the immediate queen captures
on h4
so g3 stopping that and now how do you
continue the attack well here
uh vladislav goes for the amazing f5
uh and now uh if you don't react to this
f4 is coming and then i mean
you're just getting rolled over uh so
here e captures an f5 but now
not recapturing but rather bishop to d5
grabbing hold of this beautiful diagonal
and now now things are about to get very
very dangerous
we have knight to c3 going after this
bishop
and also after the g4 pawn so you have
to defend both so bishop to f3
attacking the queen and now queen to d2
now going after this h6 pawn and you
have to be very careful here it's very
easy to
uh make a bad move in a position such as
this one because for example if queen f6
you add a defender to the pawn already
in 94
and you're you're getting uh wrecked uh
you you either have to give up this
extremely strong attacker after this uh
the df5 pawn will be nicely defended and
if you capture here then you might even
blunder your queen
so it's a it would be a pretty bad uh
position so instead
knight the g7 the absolute only way to
continue uh
this position uh to play for the
advantage with black
sacrifice the h5 pawn h6 pawn
uh we have bishop captures and now comes
knight captures on f5
so okay a bit of a pawn trade not a
sacrifice and now
black has to be very careful and here
there really is no good move uh
uh because uh what what can you play
here there's now a double attack on the
bishop here and you could move the
bishop
but the question is where there really
isn't a good square there is one good
square
and that is bishop to g5 but bishop to
g5 simply doesn't work and it doesn't
work for a very specific reason
and interestingly uh well pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
best move for black while i give you a
couple of seconds and then we're going
to discuss this
a bit more
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
absolutely crushing queen captures and
g5 uh of course
also for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show this is uh completely
winning uh
so uh sorry uh not not that knight
captures uh on h4 this is what i meant
knight captures on h4
uh black does sacrifice the queen but
not obviously by capturing knight
knight captures on h4 and this is what i
wanted to talk about here
if you ask the engine what what does the
engine think about bishop to g5
the engine says yeah that's perfectly
fine and the
there really isn't a good reply for
black but of course i knew that this was
not the case so
here i even um i gave the engine some
time i i
i went to the gym before recording and
then i uh
when i i started analyzing the position
then i went to take a shower and i
allowed
the engine to crunch the numbers here uh
in this position and then only at uh
when the engine reaches depth 27
it shows the the truth of the position
that the knight captures an h4 queen
sacrifice is just completely crushing
and there is no defense against this
whatever you do uh it's just uh
it's just completely crushing even if
you go after the knight even if you
ignore the queen
uh you just get rook captures and that's
it rook to h1 is checkmate and if you
capture the real queen captures and then
queen to h1 will be checkmate there is
no defending this
so instead after this knife captures an
h4 bishop captures an e7 was played uh
mateo
accepts the queen sacrifice but now
comes knight to f5
now threatening rook to h1 checkmate so
bishop to h4 you have to block this and
now knight captures on h4 and again you
cannot
accept this because then rook captures
and rook to h1 will be checkmate
uh so after knight to h4 queen to g5
was played and now now again black has
to be very careful there is only one
winning move here
and i'm sure you all can see it even
without pausing the video but just in
case for those of you who
really want to enjoy this game uh pause
the video one more time and find the
winning idea for black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh
finding the exact uh winning square for
the night and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
night not there uh knight the
f5 uh and this is now completely winning
for black there is nothing you can do
here rook the h1 will be checkmate
uh of course the knight cannot be
captured so queen to g6
check was played king to d8 and now
queen to f6 with check you cannot now
block with the knight because queen
captures a rook
so king to c7 now the rook is defending
the rook here so you don't really get
anything by sacrificing the queen and
the knight on f5 is preventing the queen
from capturing an f3
black white might decide to give back
the queen even though the position would
be winning for black
uh you simply do not allow this so
knight to d5
check here we have king to c6 and he was
in this position on move 27 that
material bartel resigned in the game
and what an amazing victory for
vladislav artemyev uh this is just a
a true masterpiece and uh well it's hard
you know i constantly want to go back to
the morphe saga but it's like
day after day there's a masterpiece
which is not surprising as
there are a lot more games played uh you
know nowadays
online than there were in any previous
year so i guess so
there's only going to be more and more
brilliant games for us to cover uh which
is great
uh so yeah after getting to c6 you
resign there's no way to continue
harassing the black king you might try
some
checks but for example check captures
there is no continuation for white and
any other check might be something like
this uh you might be able to
you know trick black in allowing this
but then you can capture
but it's still not gonna uh it's still
not gonna matter so king b6 can be
played and then after knight d5 checking
a7 and that's just it there's no
no continuing this so after king to c6
white resigned and what an amazing game
by vladislav artemyev
congratulations on this marvelous
achievement and i'm pretty sure everyone
everyone agrees this is a definitely a
day
improver uh okay uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank
colin nick watson henry sprague bragging
specnix
orionna and the buck which enterprises
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day